now why do you call your your podcast
professor blast-off give me a like a one
sentence summation of what professor
blast-off show is it's a discussion of
things that interest us metaphysical
science theology mystic stuff
conversations you kind of have where you
sort of wish you knew more about them
and then we bring in an expert to help
us out you can kind of heavy with this
stuff and then you also have kind of the
comedy to kind of supplement I notice
that's pretty trippy yeah we wanted to
do like sort of recreate the classroom
or I guess we're kind of the class
clowns or having fun but still learning
something why are so many comics kind of
turning to podcast these days it's easy
to do you can just grab your laptop and
make it so it's accessible and it helps
with with every everything helps with
your road work it helps all different
parts of your career and then it's fun
to just you know hang out with friends
and talk now you've kind of worked both
with Amy Schumer now and and TIG Notaro
and so what's your kind of take on that
stereotype that women aren't funny in my
experience it's not true and I think
it's been easier for men to sort of be
goofy you're sort of encouraged as a guy
to get attention from girls when you're
younger to show off in a weird way and
that's you kind of have to have that
mentality when you're doing comedy with
some comedy and for women I think they
were sort of encouraged to be pretty and
nice and and which isn't a good training
ground for a comedian but I but I think
that's all changing I don't think women
are having that much as much pressure as
I used to have to I don't know be you
know quiet and pretty that's my theory
it's a perfectly rational theory sounds
good to me
now you were a Sunday cast member of The
Groundlings correct yeah
yeah how does that how does the Sunday
cast differ from the main cast it was
really big we liked 21 people and every
week you do a brand new show it's a lot
of work and a lot of time and the main
show they'll do a run of a show and
they'll take maybe six or seven members
and we'll make a show and they'll run it
for a while whereas every week we had a
brand new show and it was a really
time-consuming it couldn't I couldn't
really do it I started doing a lot more
stand-up road stuff and it's really a
job but it was fun and I met a lot of
great people that's great oh I'm sure
your self have come off of the
groundlings there there's no yeah
there's been a lot of people I think you
don't even know about that that were
there oh that's right yeah I think
people don't know Adam Carolla was there
for a while Dec Sheppard there's a lot
of names I think people don't even know
about where did the idea for a person
like your alter ego Craig come from I've
been doing that for like as long as I
can remember I've been doing that
character it's kind of morphed it was it
seems we've gotten Dumber as the years
go on but I always sort of did that
character that's the character you do on
yeah how did you your opportunity to get
on that show come about it was just a
regular audition and they we improvise I
think they said come in where you're
either the victim of a crime or you just
committed a crime so and then they just
improvise with me and then I did one
episode and then they kept bringing me
back for other ones I never was really
like a cast member or anything
your Cregg character kind of dominates
your your YouTube page how come you
don't put more of your stand-up stuff I
am I think I'm going to it's funny
because there's like different groups
you know and you read the comments some
people get really mad
when I don't put a Craig video up if
it's something else and but some people
do ask for stand-up so I think I am
going to start putting stand-up on there
you're also involved in this you've got
this Nickelodeon a Nickelodeon animated
show kind of coming out there's a
three-minute bit of it on Nickelodeon
common on the app and I'm now writing
like an 11 minute version of it there's
kind of working with Nickelodeon and
that capacity does it kind of change
your act up a little bit and make you
have to be a little cleaner or does it
just you know not apply you can't really
write anything in that kids could hurt
themselves with you know I hate
something about a garage door and we
wrote the whole script and then they
were like oh you can't do anything with
a garage door and I was like okay and
then I had something when they were in a
pool and they were like you can't do any
in a pool unless there's someone
watching so um you still really just
think about it because I guess kids
imitate what they say so I gotta be
careful who has she'll think of
something shocking and she'll say it
whereas I may think of it but I won't
say it now you performed years ago yeah
was that before or after you started
dating Sara
Oh way before I didn't know they were
dating back then I think it was like in
2004 or something do you get those kind
of like angry ex-boyfriend calls from
Jimmy Kimmel like threatening you to
watch it constantly yeah yeah he is
constantly calling and he's very upset
how do you deal with having that kind of
high-profile status now I don't feel
like my life is different I mean I'm a
more of a camera man when we go out like
I know how to use all the different kind
of cameras to take pictures of Sara with
people that skills getting very very
good I'm very good quick photos with
blackberry phones Google I know all the
camera applications what's the better
word penis or herpes better word funnier
Oh funnier I guess I think penis is
funnier than herpes yeah who's currently
the funniest person alive Sarah
Silverman Wow look at that what a homer
man all right do you prefer stand-up or
do you prefer writing and acting it's
really a combination but definitely
stand-up over right and I don't love
writing at all but I do like performing
with other people to like stand up on
the road give me a little bit lonely
you're there for a week by yourself and
that's why I like the podcast too
because we're gonna go on a tour and you
know just to me that's that sounds fun
to go touring with a group of friends
all right well you have a good day it's
good talking to you Kyle Dunnigan thank
you very much